[Music]
so
[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back to the
2022
spring uh corporate chess league season
um i believe today is our final day of
the grand prix so after today we will
know exactly which teams are advancing
to the playoffs of the corporate chess
league unless i'm a big dummy and
there's one more week but i think this
is it i think we're done after this
um so
there's a lot to play for here tonight
uh three of our teams are pretty much
guaranteed to be in the playoffs but
that doesn't mean there isn't anything
to play for for them here tonight and
our fourth team is very much still up in
the air all five teams of the season are
going to be competing here tonight we've
got daugherty and bayer competing for
that final play-off spot so a lot for
them to uh to fight for here tonight
looking at my standings here i've got
enterprise clearly in the lead with 184
and a half points
they lead both edward jones and
ascension who are neck and neck with
128.5
and
127.5 respectively so they will be
fighting to see who gets the highest
seating
in that final four playoff
uh
tournament extravaganza so a lot of fun
there
tonight we have of course two rounds as
we always do the players play two games
per round one game with the white pieces
one with the black pieces the time
control as always is game in 10 minutes
with a zero second increment so no extra
time you get 10 minutes and that's it
and it's pretty exciting
so of course as i said dardy and bear
are the ones competing for the final
playoff spot and they're gonna get their
chance to show their stuff against each
other in the first round they are head
to head in round one here tonight that
could be the deciding round for the
corporate chess league uh who knows
maybe they get in the playoffs maybe
they play really well and they could win
the whole thing
but one of their one of their dreams
unfortunately will be ending here
tonight
uh we also have ascension squaring off
against enterprise
uh in this first round so ascension will
be looking to win this match in order to
gain that ground to against edward jones
they are just trailing by a single point
so they just need a single point more
than edward jones here tonight to steal
that number two seed and edward jones
gets the buy in the first round gets the
buy here
so they will get some free grand prix
points for having the buy
and they get a chance to score some
points as well by playing the other
extra players from the other teams in
round one
now if we make it to round two uh we
will have dirty against edward jones so
tough matchup for them but bayer also
has it pretty rough they have to play
ascension so that again could be very
important for our playoff
uh situation
and it is enterprise the number one seed
with the buy in that last round
uh so with that i think we are just
about ready to get underway games should
be starting any minute now
and i think i've got everything set up
to be ready to spectate i'm following
just about all the players
following a lot of players at least so
we should know when
the uh the round gets started
and while we wait i'm gonna do what
everybody else is doing and i'm gonna
see what's happening in the american cup
so of course today was round one of the
american cup uh and
we have uh sorry round two round one
point two of the american cup mat or
game two of match number one and so we
are broadcasting here while those
playoffs are underway to see who's
advancing and who is getting relegated
to the elimination bracket no more
champion bracket for some of those
players
so
the american cup of course only the
second most important chess event
happening right now so once the
corporate chess league gets underway we
will have our full attention there
uh but yeah let's see what's going on
let's see looks like lavon is doing well
against rey he's gonna be happy about
that
sam is battling lenny a jeffrey zhang
battling against fabi looks like fun
looks like fun
uh but without further ado we have
liftoff mr justini linguini up against
nmc gin
so of course what matches this justini
is edward jones so this is actually one
of our extra matches going on here
and let me make sure
this is actually working
we've had some problems
historically
with chess.com
but i think hopefully it's working
but for now we've got justine it looks
like we're getting into an exchange slav
where white or black played this bishop
f5 move super early so whenever you see
this you always have to be wary of yep
exactly this move queen b3 hits the pawn
on d5 hits the pawn on b7 it's
impossible to defend both of those
pieces it's actually just impossible you
can't do it you can try but you can't do
it at least not
while abiding by the laws of chess
yeah so i think just the rest of the
games haven't started yet i'm not sure
what's uh what the hold up is
but hopefully they get started soon i
don't really want to follow
the extra matches because
they aren't as important okay so i'm
going to refresh here
and let's see what we got
wow it's i love legos too up against
cross to pj super exciting stuff okay
so i love legos 2 of course is playing
for darty against bayer so this is the
match i want to follow because this
might be deciding who we get into our
playoffs this might be the one to
determine everything here
this could be it so what happened looks
like we had a four nights opening then
bishop c4 d6 and knight to g5 so black
might regret playing this d6 move uh
allowing this fried liver attack like
idea because now after bishop to e6 the
only way to comfortably defend this f7
pawn um white is actually able just to
to capture this pawn directly and white
should be much better
normally in the fried liver you go
bishop c4 first then knight f6 then
knight g5 and black must play this move
d5 in that position uh however if you
look here
black has already played d6 and white
has used that extra tempo to develop
this knight into c3 so after knight g5
this d5 line is just going to be a lot
worse
a lot worse for black not going to be
any fun that being said this position
isn't any fun either i love legos 2
definitely under a lot of pressure
let's see if i'm able to open a second
game
i certainly can try
okay see what's going on here
oh
something is happening
okay there's this watch tab now this is
interesting okay so there's justini
here is
across to pj
no
no
okay what if i x that out okay
here's cross to pj
oh it's never easy it's never easy okay
i don't think desrat is playing yet
see is c cell playing yet
don't think c cell is playing yet either
at least not that i can tell
maybe if i look over here see what's
going on over here
meanwhile i love legos too it's
absolutely tanking doesn't know what to
do about this knight on e6 just doesn't
know what to do too many things are
attacked
okay desrat is playing
but it's just it's just impossible you
just can never
we'll never know never know what's going
on in this game
i am following him i want to watch him
okay one game at a time for us fair
enough fair enough
so what's going on in deseret's game so
this is board two
of dirty versus bayer
so we've got d4 d6 okay it's slightly
weird opening an early bishop f4 by
white
and that's as far as we've made it so
still early on here black is going for
this sort of old indian type setup where
uh it's similar to the king's indian
where eventually you do normally try to
push this move e5 but black is including
this move c6 he's taking his time about
it uh maybe they'll play queen c7 maybe
knight b87 just leave all these pawns on
the third rank for a while and only when
he's good and ready is he going to push
this move e5 so this way of playing um
is called the old indian because it's
sort of an older idea but it's a
reasonable idea i
actually uh recently taught a lecture
about how to play against this opening
so if you're curious
desrat
if you want to win these games against
bayer just watch my lecture then you'll
know you'll know what to do in this
situation next time next time it crops
up
so deserve just played this move bishop
d3 black is probably going to look to
castle look to play queen to c7 knight p
to d7 and again we're just trying to
come out with uh this move e5
trying to come out with e5
okay
and
let's see here
what is going on
okay so as i suspected chess.com is
broken
and
no moves are being relayed to me so
here's the new tab with the new moves
so queen a5 got played and e4 and bishop
g4
and chess.com just didn't want to tell
me about it they just they didn't think
i deserved to know
so oh that's my email okay here we go
bishop g4 played
and
dear god i hope it shows me when moves
get played now
except it definitely won't it still says
black's clock is running after bishop g4
okay new plan chess.com live we're going
back to this one we're going back to
this one
and i've got this and let's see what
happens here
yep we can watch justini and nobody else
okay
okay i see
i see well
since we've got justini let's see what's
going on here
so we left it at this queen b3 idea
black goes queen d7
uh white's going to take on d5 take on
d5
um just no way to defend both of these
pawns so we get queen d7
takes takes knight out to a6 and what's
just going to be up a clean pawn here
and now there is this nasty tactic as
well where this this knight removes the
defender or this knight was defending
against the fork bishop takes the knight
um king d7 so you could take this knight
on d5 and prevent the loss of a full
piece
but uh that that is gonna allow bishop
to be seven here and like it's just it's
all bad
so justini
plays knight b6 here sort of a weird
idea i guess he wanted to save the
bishop by bringing it back to f3 and uh
decided that he was losing a piece
either way because all of these guys are
attacked so he throws in this weird
check black plays king c7 and also very
weird and then goes ahead and takes on
v6
and queenside castles knight d2
okay and we just have some position
where adjusting is going to be up the
full piece
all right in that case let me
see if we can find
another game to watch
always the struggle
so i'll get rid of those
we'll try
this new this new thing what happens if
i do this
close out of that
it just can't be done
it just can't be done
i don't know why this keeps happening
this can't be like
an actual chess.com just like bug for
everybody
surely it's not for everybody
i don't know i don't know in the
meantime
we'll stick with this see what's going
on
i'll flip the board so you can
see it from justini's point of view
and i am
still gonna try and see if i can find
another game
see what i can do here all right he's
playing i'm gonna click on him playing
i see him playing let's see if we get
any moves so this is gonna be board one
of dirty versus bear
so what happened here we got c4 e5 an
english opening oh and it takes on c3 so
for those fans of the sicilian you might
be familiar with the rossolimo attack
knight f3 knight c6 bishop b5 so this is
going to be a lot like that except with
the colors reversed black is the one
going bishop b4 taking here on c3 and
then going c5 and so the ideas are going
to be similar but white is going to have
a much easier game than uh
if this had happened with colors
reversed because of course he has an
extra move so he gets to play things
like d4 very easily
um but the idea is going to be similar
then it looks like we had this move
queen d3
which of course runs into this fork on
e4 always got to look out for that so
black picked up an early piece oh and
now black's taking on c4
yeah this seems to just all be going
black's way
then uh we got this b5 b4 idea which is
kind of weird and then eventually black
realizes that this pawn on e4 is
actually pinned cannot take that bishop
because of e1
and that's how we ended up in the
current position
and again
i don't think chess.com is actually
relaying the moves here i think i'm just
going to be frozen here forever
while that clock runs
which is a shame
it is a real shame
okay what if i refresh
do i get new moves if i refresh
i don't get anything if i refresh
that's so sad
okay
c cell i want c cell what can i do to
get c cell o 603
what can i do
all right i'm going to click on playing
once again
here's this game
and i am just looking for a single move
to come my way
just this once what happened by the way
cecil was crushing
no cecil is not crushing he's getting
crushed that's right we saw
white lose a piece see cell in trouble
then this takes on d5 h3 e5
and now he took on g2 okay takes takes
and yeah it looks like black broke
through over here we got a trade of the
knight for the bishop
and white had a little bit of pressure
here
um
but it looks like black is still just
going to be up a clean piece tough to
attack the king with only the rook and
the queen left and yeah now i can see
the clocks moving back and forth but i
still it's not going to show me any
moves
okay but i can click reload
this is this is great i'll just i'll
click reload
to get my new moves
what
is queen h7
i don't understand did this actually
happen
did this actually happen
i'll be impressed
very impressive that happened
it did happen
what's going on okay here's the updated
king f8
oh
rookie two was played first what
okay
okay
i think we're gonna go to a break try to
figure out these technical issues
because
this is not working
so hopefully we're back with a with a
more functioning chess.com um if not
good luck to these players and uh so far
so fun see you guys around
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
so
do
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back to the
spring season of the corporate chess
league so these technical issues are not
going to go away tonight unfortunately
so unfortunately we do have to sign off
thank you as always to all the players
playing this lovely event uh we always
enjoy having you guys here and we will
be live with a working broadcast for the
playoffs uh unfortunately it looks like
chess.com is just not gonna let us
spectate any of the games today not much
we can do if the platform we're on is
not functioning for us today uh so thank
you guys who did tune in and i hope to
see you for the playoffs
my name is ben caleb denby it still is
caleb denby this has been the corporate
chess league spring season thank you all
so much for joining me and we will see
you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you